do
daylight tries to spook you out but this
old dog really needed some new tricks
this first-person survival game is
bogged down by poor writing and endless
cliches you might be startled a few
times but you can only see so many
drawers fly out of bureaus before you
know when and where the so-called
surprises will occur daylight is
procedurally generated but it's no less
predictable than a typical linear
adventure
it just recycles the same basic frights
in different places
turning the initial scares into tepid
shrugs you could think of daylight as a
combination of slender the arrival and
outlast the slender comparison comes
from how you must escape each area
without coming face-to-face with ghostly
stalkers the outlast connection is the
setting which focuses on a now-defunct
asylum where terrible events once
occurred you move through each major
region as a young woman named Sarah
mapping progress on the cellphone you're
always holding you come across memos
personal Diaries and other written
remnants of the past collect enough of
these remnants and you may proceed to
the next stage of your journey there's a
story to piece together hear a story
partially driven by the insidious
disembodied voice that accompanies you
it takes several playthroughs for that
story to come into better focus but the
silly payoff isn't worth the tedium of
getting there
given the bad dialogue it's tempting to
presume that daylight is aiming for
b-movie appeal but the game isn't bad in
the good way it's just bad life is but a
butterfly's dream remarks your unseen
guide doing his best to make silly
nonsense sound like a deep thought Sara
says out of the blue you can't escape
destiny proving that she's watched
plenty of movies but adding nothing to
the story she's actually a part of by
the time a newspaper clipping raises the
possibility that a construction project
was built on a Native American burial
ground
you can only laugh daylight borrows all
sorts of ideas but does nothing to
enhance them like a discount Halloween
scary sound CD there are some nice
atmospheric touches like the rapid
flutter you hear when of pursuing which
approaches when your pursuer draws close
you can burn away her presence with a
flare which leads to a few decent
frights as you quickly reach for your
flare button if such details are
overshadowed by daylight's bizarre
randomness and dated visuals Sara will
scream in response to nothing at all
or comments on events in ways that make
absolutely no sense the game is most
interesting facet is the way it allows
you to connect the game to your twitch
TV channel but that feature only
contributes to the sense of sloppiness
viewers can type keywords into the chat
window and trigger a few scares of their
own in the game hearing a panicked cry
because somebody in your channel typed
scream as a curiosity but only a
curiosity who is it that screaming and
what exactly is she afraid of daylight
doesn't care screams are scary and
that's all that matters
take daylights claims to procedural
generation with a grain of salt while
the corridor mazes change somewhat from
one playthrough to the next layouts
remain consistent enough that you can
easily rush through them when making
return visits and yes indeed
daylight lets you sprint at full speed
all the time which destroys any sense of
tension given its procedural generation
and twitch integration daylight seems to
invite multiple playthroughs the irony
here is that it isn't worth playing
through even once